[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 voici l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale de ce jeudi 26
décembre cadeaux inutiles de mauvais
goût ou en double chaque année le père
noël ne fait pas que des heureux
solution pour que ces présents ne prenne
pas trop la poussière les revendre
aujourd'hui plus d'un tiers des français
n'hésiteraient plus à franchir le pas
aurélie rose est allé vérifier cette
information à montigny le bretonneux
bien sûr comme chaque année j'ai eu des
chocolats j'ai eu des bijoux j'ai eu des
parfums et j'ai eu de l'argent très
généreux beaucoup de cadeaux est très
sympa et eut encore passé je pense mais
il m'a déjà datés pas ma fille chaque
année après noël deux camps s'affrontent
celles et ceux qui sont satisfaits de
leurs cadeaux et les autres moi je suis
pas du tout tubes des années 80 donc ça
me direz c'est pas du tout j'ai eu ça
j'ai eu plein de choses comme ça a fait
des choses droits des livres du foie
bronze qui sont pas que j'aime pas moi
je préfère me faire mes cadeaux moi même
les voilà pour les déçus de noël une
solution la revente sur des sites
internet ou encore dans des enseignes
spécialisés dans l'achat vente dans
cette boutique de montigny le bretonneux
les revente d'objets augmente de 30%
pendant cette période principalement des
doublons ou alors
ils ont vendu alors ils ont anticipé ils
ont vendu leur téléphone avant noël
savent qu'ils vont recevoir de l'argent
le 25 et vont venir
aussi acheté un téléphone nouvelle
génération les jeux vidéo ou les
consoles font également partie des
articles les plus revendus selon un
sondage paru cette année 34 % des
français se disent prêts à revendre
leurs cadeaux
les gens sont de plus en plus ouverts à
revendre leurs cadeaux
on a plus en fait c'est honte d'aller
acheter ou vendre de l'occasion
maintenant c'est c'est très clairement
rentrés dans les moeurs
la tendance ces dernières années à
l'économie circulaire pouces est
également de plus en plus de français à
se séparer de leurs cadeaux inutiles à
noël qui aurait pu tourner au vinaigre
pour ses deux enfants flavio et paulo se
sont retrouvés bloqués à bordeaux après
l'annulation de leur tgv en raison de la
grève
la perspective de passer le réveillon
avec leur père à montigny le bretonneux
s'est retrouvé ainsi menacé c'était sans
compter sur la générosité et de
plusieurs chauffeurs de taxi et
girondins qui propose d'acheminer
gratuitement les enfants bloquées par la
mobilisation sociale pendant les fêtes
les deux jeunes ont pu être ainsi
emmener jusqu à montigny le bretonneux
un trajet de 550 km qui aurait dû être
facturé normalement 1500 euros un beau
cadeau de noël dans l'actualité
également ce triste anniversaire il ya
tout juste vingt ans la tempête lothar
s'abattait sur la france dans les
yvelines les rafales de vent avaient
causé d'importants dommages au domaine
du château de versailles des vitres
cassées et surtout trente mille arbres
disparus dont le tulipier de virginie
est planté sous marie antoinette suite
aux intempéries une exceptionnelle
mobilisation a eu lieu une aide de 35
millions d'euros par l'état et 2,5
millions d'euros également récolté grâce
aux entreprises associations et
particuliers
ainsi dix mille arbres ont pu être
remises en terre le parc aujourd'hui
renaît avec ses arbres remarquables et
la replantation de 450 chaînes de
l'allée de saint cyr vient d'être lancé
pendant les vacances de fin d'année de
nombreuses activités vous sont proposés
pour vous occuper aux clayes-sous-bois
une patinoire écologique s'est installé
pour la quatrième année consécutive à
l'espace philippe noiret vous pouvez
venir patiner sur place jusqu'au 4
janvier tarif de 3 euros pour 30 minutes
matériel fourni et des animations sont
également organisées sur le parvis du
cinéma théâtre avis recueillis sur place
par mathilde et demi elle est agréable
pour les petits et puis le pape il est
de l'autre côté au cinéma avec le garçon
donc on arrive à occuper tout le monde
j'en ai jamais fait j'ai toujours voulu
l'essayer
je trouve que c'est bien c'est amusant 1
de glee c'est bon je sais pas j'aime
bien c'est pas loin de chez nous avec du
coup c'était l'occasion pour eux de
tester en plus à l'intérieur donc fait
parfois je fais ce que je peux mon petit
fils veut absolument viennent en faire
avec lui alors j'ai la compagne et pour
les habitants de guyancourt et des
environs une patinoire éphémère est
également installée au pavillon
waldeck-rousseau jusqu'au 31 décembre
enfin si vous êtes plutôt balade en
forêt pour ses congés des visites sont
organisées par le parc naturel régional
de la haute vallée de chevreuse
l'objectif permettre aux adultes et aux
enfants de venir découvrir apprécier les
plantes sauvages et surtout comestibles
le reportage de gwendal saintilan
je vous montre un geste qui remonte à la
nuit des temps à pratiquer ce geste avec
toutes sortes de plantes pour en
extraire le suc évidemment est-ce qu'il
faut extraire et appliqué sur les
piqûres blessure c'est ça c'est ce jules
acquis au soleil et vert fluo magnifique
alors les oeufs bacon pour le collyre
tout ce que l'on peut dire vous offre ou
récupérer les sucs et vous le mettez
dans l'oeil sans problème orties
pissenlit bears trois plantes sauvages
mais comestibles souvent considérés
comme de mauvaises herbes dans notre
jardin
stéphane loriot animateur au parc
naturel de chevreuse organise des
sorties découvertes pour les faire
connaître au grand public
quand on s'appelle la halle hier elle a
le goût et les vertus médicinales
delahaye alors que ce n'est pas de live
donc je proposais ces personnes qui
disposent souvent d'un jardin je leur ai
expliqué qu'il disposait dans leur
périmètre proche d'un véritable
patrimoine en termes de cartes des menus
quoi manger au plus proche donc là nous
sommes vraiment dans la les champions de
ce qu'on appellerait la filière courte
qu'il comprenne que le patrimoine
naturel nous offre également chez les
porcs sauvages
un panel de plantes sauvages savoureuse
et tellement nourrissante bref tout non
lic avant sont là profitons-en
évidemment
entre 30 et 50 plants expliquer à chaque
sortie ce sont de véritables surprises
nutritionnel que l'on peut goûter et
apprécier convivialité partage de
savoirs un véritable moment de détente
je propose parfois des ateliers avec les
scolaires où on fait une sortie
découverte et l'après midi une
dégustation avec avec plusieurs recettes
je le fais que des adultes également
avec avec des enfants quand les gens me
disent je regarderai désormais mon
jardin différemment le but étant
évidemment qu'ils comprennent que leur
pelouse n'est pas qu'une pelouse est qu
un massif de fleurs fallait bien d'un
simple massifs de fleurs
je leur interdis pas d'avoir une pelouse
et d'avoir un massif de fleurs un massif
de fleurs cultivées mais qu'il comprenne
qu'une friche
elle s'adapte forcément d'elle-même et
que dans cette friche on a patrimoine
insoupçonné may hamm un patrimoine
remarquable qu'on peut utiliser à sa
guise sans pour autant me mets la
ressource au contraire on génère on
fabrique une voie supplémentaire bien
son périmètre que l'on choix différent
il faut déchirer la pole n'hésitez pas
déchiré la feuille
alors observer les plantes de votre
jardin vous pourrez peut-être et
découvrir quelques-unes de ces plantes
insoupçonnées mais qui regorge de saveur
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi demain même heure vous
retrouverez michael et demi d'euros aux
commandes de cette édition d'information
locale ce soir ne manquez pas un numéro
exclusif du 7-8 loisirs le dernier de
cette année 2010 9 belle fête sur tv 78
[Musique]